everyday consumers across Europe by
millions of products taking for granted
that these goods are safe the European
Commission works together with
manufacturers importers retailers
experts and 31 national authorities to
make sure dangerous products are
detected and reported quickly in the
European rapid alert system this network
works all year round day-in day-out
scientists inspectors and technicians
carry out tests and checks to detect
hazardous products products considered
dangerous for consumers our signal to
the authorities to either recall the
product directly from consumers or to
have it taken off the shops however
given that Goods circulate in Europe the
same product may still be on sale in
other EU countries thanks to the
European rapid alert system information
on dangerous products found on the
market is quickly circulated all over
Europe
every week a list of detected dangerous
products is published on the web
everybody can consult this website and
check what products should not be for
sale European rapid alert system for
dangerous products keeping European
consumers safe
you